the jurogan experience well
i think some guys can at certain stages
right like there's moments and fights
where don't you feel
like you're in a zone sometimes and it's
just everything's flowing
saturday night saturday night yeah i
felt good all backstage because
um leading up to the fight everyone's
like ring rust ring rust so
i was kind of waiting for some feeling
to say where's roon rust right but i
felt great backstage
and i preferred fighting with with no
crowd did you really yeah
can you get you get to the to the apex
and it's like
you get there you wrap your hands you
warm up you fight there's no hanging
around for five hours backstage and
just it's like a gym right you get there
you warmed and just go compete so
i i preferred it for sure do you prefer
it because of the
there's no noise no distractions no
nothing and you can hear your coaches
clearly oh yeah yeah instructions
clearly yeah
i'm a very good listener to my coaches
so i
wouldn't say i prefer it but it was i it
was good i enjoyed it
you have been in a very interesting
position over the last few years
where you are one of the top ufc welterw
welterweights but just be
because of bad fortune just things just
haven't totally lined up correctly
yeah fights have fallen apart injuries
and sicknesses and a bunch of [ __ ] went
down and
you're until saturday night you you had
been
kind of ignored by a lot of fans like a
lot of people
don't understand what the level you're
at they don't understand i think they
saw it
for the brief moment that happened that
you fought saturday night but then
unfortunately there's the injury you
know bilal has the
accidental eye poke and it's another
you know another unfortunate situation
but at least
during that first round yeah the first
round
they got to see your skill level yeah
for sure i was just getting warmed up as
well i got
over the last year and a half i've
learned so much that what i wanted to
show and
to have that that incident happen it's
like it's one in a million right you
when you're when you're preparing the
camp you're like
i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do that and
then when that happened i was like
i thought i thought okay take five
minutes
late let it play out a little bit and
then hopefully we can fight again but
he's just he's always that bad actually
his eyes are so fast
and then was it it was a not quite it
wasn't a pokemon i wanted a poke
it was like a knuckle if you could see
the picture it's like
you're kicking right so yeah when you're
kicking you don't hold you don't hold
your fist and kick like this right you
kind of
use it to momentum to swing your arm
back and
others doing it it kind of just like
grazed his eyes
well not crazy it kind of went deep but
it grazed his eyes a bit
and then but was it like the front
knuckles it looked like it from the
pictures
yeah i couldn't tell i didn't feel it i
thought it was the the the
kid that got him in his body and then he
fell down at the start you know the one
started grabbing his eyes i was like oh
[ __ ] i got i got
i caught him in his eye you know right i
thought it was just literally
the kitten i caught him because i did
this and then i think dana put a photo
on his instagram jamie i think it was a
knuckle you weren't you weren't doing
this for sure it's uh so unfortunate man
but i mean for you what i was
getting at was that it has to be so
frustrating here you are
another ad blocker here here you are you
have this long layoff
yeah and fights keep getting canceled
and then you finally get a fight
you're performing really well and then
this happens
it's like the bad luck right the last
the last year or so
just one after another after the woodley
fight i meant to fight woodley you know
um
in london in march and um had that
cancelled the week before
on the sunday before the fight and then
from there just
bad luck bad luck bad luck for clearing
down so
so yeah it's like that yeah it's like
the bottom of your finger yeah so it's
not like it's straight
forward it's like it's just getting in
there
that's terrible and it wasn't the
eyeball right it's like the
under the eyelid yeah you know because
so i saw bilal on sunday in the casino
in vegas and
his eyes was fine just the it's the lid
the um
that was burst but yeah he said the the
vision started returning the next day
and now he said there's no permanent
damage so he's going to be okay he got
his
lid stitched up yeah i wish him well so
i feel good
yeah he's a great guy and uh it was a
great opponent for you too because he's
so relentless he's you know he's
constantly moving forward he's a tough
guy
he's durable yeah he's very very very
caught him with a head kick in the first
round and
i kind of rushed my work a little bit i
kind of went wild and started swinging
him swinging for him but
i should have picked my shots a little
bit better but he's tough he's durable
but
he doesn't beat me in any given day you
know i i believe
it will fight ten times i'll beat him
ten times and
that's just it is he was a late
stepping for hamzap fell out and i think
you should go back work his way back up
and then hopefully we can meet somewhere
down the line but
for now i'm looking towards the tower
shot i'm looking towards being a world
champion
do you think that uh the title shot is
warranted just because your previous
work
and just because of the great first
round that you had but i mean do you
feel like there's any unfinished
business because of the way that fight
ended
yeah um i don't believe so i think
from the first round i'm normally i'm a
slow starter right so if that's my
if that's my first round you're not
making it to the to the fifth
you know so um i think everyone saw
word fight was going and it wouldn't
have made it to
number five so i understand your
confidence i really do
and this is not to demean that at all
but you gotta
you gotta give the guy an opportunity
right like
you know what i'm saying like if here's
my point if the fight went the first
round if the ipoke didn't happen
the referee just stopped the fighter but
like what are you doing well you know
where this fight's going
well you don't know where a fight's
going because fights are crazy like
weird [ __ ] happens
people slip guy gets them in a choke
like weird stuff happens
you know people get injured you know
someone throws a calf kick all of a
sudden your leg goes numb
you get hit with a punch weird [ __ ]
happens you
fights are crazy that's crazy but um you
know what i'm saying though i know
no no i know what you're saying but i
would have i would have won that fight
clearly joe normally
normally i'm i'm a slow starter in the
first round right i know like
so i would i felt great tonight and
even i'm uh if i felt good bilal's not
beating me
completely appreciate your confidence
but as a fan of you yeah and
as a fan of bilal yeah um i don't think
it would be a bad thing to run back
not straight away i'm looking to that's
my nine my nine
fight right in a row um eight i won an
a51 streak four below um
i would have won the fight that'd be
nine fight um without without loss
from getting um beat by usman five six
years ago so
i feel like i've done enough work now to
prove that uh
i belong at least in normal contender
fight or title fight uh
you know so i i can totally appreciate
your position but i can also appreciate
below no i i know where it's coming from
i would say if i was him i'd probably do
the same thing right it's ranked number
one for in 14 and
yeah this big opportunity's first main
event um number three guy in the world
so
i know where he's approaching it from
but i am looking
looking for my own career right i want
to look towards the title shot i
understand
hopefully we'll get it yeah you've had
all these
weird situations where things fell apart
it's uh it's
very unfortunate and uh did you feel
like the hamza fight was strange too
because like here's this guy
who has only had a few fights in the ufc
he's got a lot of hype behind him
because he's had like the mir sharp
fight was a great result he looked
fantastic
but then all of a sudden he's fighting
you yeah like he was weird right because
we will two weeks before that dana white
came out on
his uh and i was never gonna fight
leonardo no one in top five
but then next week he's like leo you
want to find him i was like
you just said i'm too high-ranked for
him but
um where do you think that came from i
don't know i don't know i think everyone
was turning him down
you know and um everyone's turning me
down as well so just like okay
you want to fight him i was okay look
what about kobe is that cold said no
what about mastodon master also now what
about wonder boy wonder boy is injured
that's okay you got the most hype in the
division now
um that i could like piggyback off to
get to a world title shot right and
this was a kid they know what build him
up because this this kid that can't be
beaten is
tough and so i was like okay i'll go out
there i'll i'll i'll fight him and
when i beat him i'll fight football
towel and that was my plan right to use
um this hype they're building around him
to get me to a world title shot come on
oh i'm always looking towards the title
shot right so anyway i can get there
easier
um other than your hamster to get there
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience